all right another week another episode
of loki also spoiler alert i don't think
i gave you that
alert last week anyhow spoiler alert
again as always not gonna be a
play-by-play i just like getting
spoilerish when i talk about tv episodes
an episode where last week i was like we
don't have lady loki's backstory and
people were like dude
her name is sylvie anyhow the beginning
of this episode we see her as a little
kid in asgard which is great to see
asgard you know pre
blowing up and the tva was like she's
playing with toys getter and they get
her you see these people getting
vaporizers or whatever the tva does and
this kid's like nope peace out and she
goes through the quantum leap door and
escapes the only thing is dude i don't
want to [ __ ] too much but i do need a
little more than that you know
it's because this little kid didn't know
anything about the tva she didn't know
how to evade them that's something you
need to learn so i refuse to believe she
was like all right going to go through
this door and
hang out in apocalypses forever because
i know i need to do that i don't know
why she would know she needs to do that
that's something you need to learn so by
implication she's just evaded capture
many times until she found out
she has to hang out in apocalypses in a
world where apparently they've
gotten a lot of loki's before because
there's that world of loki's at the end
i'm kind of getting ahead of myself but
we'll get there all this is to say
i'm sure we'll find out next week i'm
just i need more
that's what these videos are it's just
me talking about things and joking about
things like
what's there to talk about i'll tell you
the important things loki's stance baby
that these legs look like a pair of
snips he's just like bam
loki of asgard welcomes you to the party
zone so sylvia and loki's stance were
hanging out in their apocalypse zone
where this moon's gonna crash into this
planet they're just
accepting their fate and then there's a
timeline shift a breach a hardcore
variance that's happening which we
learned in back to the future the power
of love because a baby loki via
multi-dimensional
love fest which i feel like is a really
clever way of saying masturbation
technically i got anyhow i guess that
would just wreck the multiverse so
anyhow the tva gets them
and then puts loki in this kind of it's
basically a hell loop
it's the hell loop from lucifer though
lucifer wasn't the first thing to ever
come up with hell loop the concept is
there's a scenario that's a painful
scenario that you just have to relive
over and over and over again though i'm
getting mixed signals from
this loop because the scenario is he's
on asgard
and then lady siff walks around the
corner and then knees him in the balls
punches him in the face because he cut
her hair i guess that was the prank we
didn't see it but that's
you find out that's what happened and
she leaves comes back same thing
knee in the balls punch in the face and
the reason i'm getting mixed signals
about this because the concept of a hell
lib usually it's like the person's just
you know they're crying or whatever and
it's all super painful but they have to
live through the experience
they can't change it and that's what
makes it painful but loki with lady sif
i mean he gets down on his knees and
begs for forgiveness and he's like i'm
really sorry i just i thought it would
be funny it was wrong for me to do she
still insults him and leaves but
he doesn't get needing the balls and
punched in the face which means he can
take
action to avoid the pain so can he block
with his knee block with his arm and
then you know
counter-attack regardless the lesson is
cause enough pain to someone
and they'll apologize to stop the pain
which means loki did
every youtube apology ever like ever how
sincere is it looked pretty sincere from
loki but
the motivation was to get the pain to
stop so
question for the philosophers i suppose
i just found it funny that he could take
action
in some ways but not others it doesn't
really explain it i mean we can
make the leap that yeah he has to
apologize and that's the only way and
that's the lesson there but he seemed to
be still getting
kicked in the balls and punched in the
face after that like the loop kept going
anyhow owen wilson's character dies
dumb i hate that i just i hate the fact
that it happened
he just gets vaporized he's thinking
about a jet ski
and then bam because he starts having
faith in loki and
that's actually a really important thing
this episode showed it showed the power
of a thought words are that powerful
because perception's powerful
ideas are powerful and this episode
shows that all loki had to do
was tell owen wilson like you're the
biggest liar because you're lying to
yourself and he goes into his hell loop
and that was enough owen wilson's like
yeah maybe sometimes it's all it takes
it's silly with that one
agent one agent's like okay when you
were in my head you showed me stuff show
me again she shows her again and
they're all starting to find out well at
least two of them one of which got
vaporized so one of them are starting to
find out that they had lives
before the tva they weren't made by
these gods which at the beginning of
this episode you're like oh they're real
then sylvie throws a sword at once
slicing its head off with
pretty boss move right there gonna be
real but the head just falls down it's
just big
electronic robot heads so they're like
who created the tva fascinating question
who created the tva possibly nobody it's
possibly all all right thought
experiment time you know i like thought
experiments so all right imagine
me back in 2009 it's already been that
long
wow but imagine past me in 2009 got a
visit from
future me and future me had a camera
gave that to past me and said hey you
need to take this camera
and start doing youtube videos all right
so past me took the camera
gifted from future me and did youtube
videos
knowing that one day in the future i
would have to take that camera go back
to past me
and give past me that camera and that is
the loot but
at that point where did the camera come
from the camera seemingly has no
beginning
because it's stuck in this infinity loop
it effectively
is never created granted this is the
most durable camera ever that will
apparently never wear down from use for
the sake of this thought experiment
that's what it is but
i feel like if you can answer that
question you might be able to answer
where the tva came from maybe
i don't know then loki gets vaporized
he's about to profess his heart and soul
to sylvie and then he gets vaporized
with one of those sticks
i was like oh that's double dumb am i
do i care to watch the next two owen
wilson and loki were what i liked about
the show now there's no owen wilson
and loki but there's a post credit scene
where loki wakes up in this world
with a bunch of other loki's or at least
a few other loki's loki's first question
should be
wait a minute are you my son did sylvia
and i get down did she come to the party
zone no no
my first thought was like okay loki's
still in it does that mean owen wilson's
still in it do people that get vaporized
not get vaporized they just
go into this other world is he hanging
out in some owen wilson world with drill
bit taylor and
oscar from armageddon a world that'll
only be known as
wow no but the whole who created the tva
thing is very interesting it's an
interesting thought
interesting concept this episode's
definitely much better than the previous
episode
i feel like the previous episode with
the one bit of information that was
relevant and vital from that episode
could have been 10 minutes at the
beginning of this episode and then led
right into this episode in which this
episode would be closer to an hour long
and it would just be one episode it'd be
fine i do want to know what the mc's
fetish
with mid-century technology is you look
at the intro to loki it looks like the
intro to wanda vision or something
like why the black and white why the
film grain what why the mid-century
aesthetic i don't know you even see some
mid-century tech in here
someone played bioshock and they were
like we want that
we want that in here not going to make
it horror though we don't want to scare
the children
we'll just make them feel like they can
get snatched out of their rooms and
vaporize
all right so episode four of loki have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you